-We're about to play
"Hey Robot."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Hey, hey, robot ♪
♪ Hey, robot ♪
-I'm going to need some help,
so joining me now
is the star of the new film
"Nightmare Alley,"
which is in theaters now.
Please welcome the one and only
Cate Blanchett!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
Cate, here's how the game works.
Okay, this is based on a real
board game called "Hey Robot"
that you can play at home.
It's like the classic game
"Password,"
but your partner is
a smart speaker.
Okay, so first, I will pick
a card with a word on it,
and then we'll take turns --
-That looks like a sex aid.
[ Laughter ]
That doesn't look like --
What is that?
I know I'm on Zoom,
but what is that?
-No, no.
[ Laughter ]
It's not --
Your kids can see this.
This is totally --
This is a smart speaker.
-Okay.
-This is a smart speaker.
-A "smart speaker."
-That's correct.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, whatever.
-I'll pick a card
with a word on it.
[ Laughs ]
-Okay.
-And we are going to take turns
asking a question, okay?
And all we want is
to get the speaker
to say that word
somewhere in its answer.
Okay?
And if it does, you get a point.
We can't say the word,
obviously.
Okay? I'll start. You'll see.
Here we go.
-Okay.
-Alright, here we go.
Oh. Alright, so, I have to get
it to say the word "rubber."
Okay.
Alexa, what are tires made of?
-Here's something I found
on the web.
According to servicecity.com,
the main materials
for the production of tires
are rubber, which is --
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I don't know if I'm going to
make it through the whole game.
-This has nothing to do with
the "smart speaker."
This has to do with --
This is the Olympiad, isn't it?
-That's exactly right.
-I'm meant to do some sort of
physical, active --
my physical prowess --
-That's correct. Exactly.
New Year's resolution.
Yeah, even if you --
So, you're up.
And you have to get the smart
speaker, which is what it is,
to say the word "mushrooms."
-Apar-- Alexa, apart from beef,
what is in beef Stroganoff?
-Here is what I found.
According to cooksinfo.com,
beef Stroganoff is a dish
consisting of thin slices
of cooked beef
and sliced mushrooms.
[ Ding! ]
-Oh, come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
You're good.
We got to take this on the road!
Oh! Oh, my God!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my God!
[ Laughing ]
It is my turn again.
Unfortunately, I have to get it
to say -- Oh.
"Walrus."
[ Laughter ]
Alright.
The walrus was...
Alexa, according to the Beatles,
who was Paul?
-Here's what I found
from the Web.
Sir Paul McCartney has been
hailed as a genius
by St. Vincent for his work
with the new remix of his song.
The Beatles legend asked
39-year-old Annie Clark,
real name Annie Clark, to appear
in the remix of his song
"Women and Wives," from this
year's "McCartney III Imagined"
compilation, which features
a new version of his song.
Was that helpful?
-No.
No, that wasn't --
-Thanks for your feedback.
-Yeah, you're welcome.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That wasn't helpful.
Now it is your turn,
my partner, Cate,
whenever you're ready.
-Oh, gosh.
Alexa, in Lewis Carroll's
"Alice in Wonderland,"
who was on the beach?
-Sorry, I don't have
an answer for that.
-Oh, well, that's not
my problem.
[ Laughter ]
-Let me start. Let me say it.
-Alexa, according to Lewis
Carroll's "Alice in Wonderland,"
who was on the beach?
-Here's something I found
on the web.
According to sea.edu,
on the beach,
terror strikes Robinson Crusoe,
the first of many castaways to
confront destiny on the sand.
-Yep.
[ Laughter ]
-This is going well.
-That's fantastic.
[ Buzzer ]
Ready? Here we go. Ready?
Alexa, what are the top three
animals with tusks?
-According to an Alexa answers
contributor, elephants.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Buzzer ]
-So close.
I'm skipping that one, okay?
-Okay, one more.
-Alright, try one more.
Here we go. This is it.
-Alexa, can you name an animal
with tusks that begins with W?
-Sorry, I don't know that.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Buzzer ]
-Ah, nice try.
[ Laughs ]
What?
-She knows even less than I do.
-She's like, "I don't know --
welephant?"
[ Laughter ]
Alright, here we go.
The last one, let's make this
work, here we go.
Alright, I have to make
the smart speaker say...
"oink."
[ Laughter ]
I think I can do this, right?
Alexa, what sound does
a pig make?
-Okay. Here's animal noises.
A pig goes --
[ Pig oinking ]
[ Laughter ]
Which would you like next?
-Does that count, judges?
[ Dinging ]
That's it, we did it! Alright!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Cate Blanchett!